[Music]
with the change to the kickoff formation
in
2018 one of the big realities for the
nfl onside kicks are much harder to
recover which means teams that are
trailing late in the game having a
harder time getting back into the game
for that reason the denver broncos have
proposed chris
a refinement to the rules that would
allow that fourth and 15 play to be used
as a way to retain possession under
certain circumstances when a team is
trailing now as it turns out seven of
the eight members of the competition
committee are in favor of this the one
hold out giants co-owner john mara who
says what are we the afl or the arena
football yeah yeah yeah yeah what are
the arena football league actually it's
more like the alliance of american
football because that's what they use
and look if you can't recover the onside
kick if the new format aimed at making
the play safer makes it harder to
recover the ball the nfl should be in
favor of this they should want to give
the team that is trailing a better
chance to keep possession to keep games
interesting beyond a point where they
otherwise would be over i guess what i
get worried about is that it becomes too
easy to keep a team that's been
dominated for three three quarters and
plus fourth and fifteen not fourth and
five yeah i i i understand that still at
the same time i think what i worry about
is just little things like this the oh
oh you know a quarterback throws the
ball into triple coverage and now the
they call pass interference and now it's
first down or you know a quarterback
gets hit on a judgment call and they
call ruffing the passer and maybe i
didn't think it was roughing the passer
at home now they get a first down that
way and the drive gets to continue so i
guess i don't know where i stand with
this i wish they would find a better way
to still do the onside kick
and i know that's probably not going to
happen because of player safety and all
of that but fourth and 15 i'm not sure
so sure i want to back that 100 yet
either i guess i need to see some of the
statistics uh and and just see where it
is at like the last 10 yards 10 years as
far as conversions on fourth and 15th
yeah it's slim it's low it's slim and
you know what here's the thing though
it's one thing to go forward on fourth
and 15 during a game it's another thing
when you know you're coming out on you
know this is it i mean it's it i think
it has a different feel to it and it
does create a whole new set of
statistics as is it's going to be an
insight certainly yeah i like to have
teams
i like it because if you do
try this right people like it then
that's when the kickoff maybe moves
toward fourth and 15 across the board
that where you punt or have a fake punt
or have a scrimmage play or you know i
like the idea of putting your offense
out there creating the impression you're
going to go for it and you got your ben
roethlisberger pooch punt over the head
of the defense it bounces around inside
the five yeah so i i like the idea of
the fourth and 15 because it could make
the kickoff more exciting by making
fourth and 15 the new kickoff play and
you'd have more return you'd have more
excitement to have more football instead
of what we currently have with the
kickoff where they're just kicking the
ball out of bounds most of them yeah no
i i don't disagree with you there i
think it can add some excitement to the
to the football game in general and i
think that you know i don't know i guess
there's a lot of things i think about
here i also think about gosh here's a
defense let's say who's been on the
field because their team's up by 20
points or 14 points and now you know
it's the two minute drill and the team's
going down the field and they go down
and chew up clock and the defense has to
stay on the field a long long time and
all of a sudden they got to come right
back out the next player if you're
recovering on sidekick it's the same
thing you're saying for that next
exactly for that next play that's where
i just things i'm just throwing out
there that i've gone through you know
what you've actually i i hate to give
you this credit i made a good point
because this is a reason why a tangible
reason why the statistics will be
different exactly a normal fourth and 15
is going to be very different from hey
you just gave up a touchdown right which
may have been at the end of a 15-play
drive right now go play another play no
doubt and then the offense of course is
going to have time in between the extra
point to formulate okay how do we want
to attack this what do we want to do
here uh but you know for pure excitement
i think i guess i just don't want to
make it too easy on the team trying to
come back i guess that's where i worry
about as a as a football purist that way
yeah
there's a point where purist has to give
way to keeping the games exciting as
long as possible yeah and i get you
there the onside kick is useless right
now the commissioner was asked several
years ago who he roots for and he said i
root for the team that's trailing yeah
the nfl wants the team that's behind to
have a chance to tie it up and maybe win
it and keep it exciting for as long as
possible we got plenty more pft live for
you we'll be back with more right after
this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports